- You know, after what
we've seen in the last year,
that new rail is really,
really significantly needed.
As much as Rumble is
needed as a video platform,
I actually believe that the actual rail,
the cloud, the infrastructure,
the service is really,
really needed for the entire internet.
The free and open
internet is under attack.
And we need to provide the
rail as a common carrier,
as close to a common carrier as possible
for everyone else out there,
all the other businesses,
all the other, churches,
everything, universities,
it kind of spreads into
every sector out there.
And we really wanna provide
that infrastructure.
(upbeat music)
- I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today
is the CEO of Rumble, Chris Pavlovski,
welcome to the Rubin Report.
- Dave, thanks for having me
really excited to be on today.
- All right, I guess we have
to do like the disclaimers
or whatever you wanna
call it right up front.
Yes, everybody knows that
Rumble and Locals have merged.
There was an acquisition.
So this is not going to be an
attack you kind of interview.
But the reason we wanted
to do this was to clarify
some of the reasons that
we're doing this partnership
in the first place.
So I'm just putting that part out there
before I do anything else.
Can you just tell me a little bit
about how and why you created Rumble?
Because this is not
something that just magically
appeared out of nowhere a year ago.
You've been working on
this thing for a long time.
- No, I have for sure.
So, I've actually been in this
space for two decades now.
I started, it was like 2001.
So yeah, it's exactly two decades.
And I remember it was about 2005.
I had one of my friends
send me an ICQ message
or an MSN messenger message.
And they're like, hey,
check this site out.
And it was YouTube.
And at the time my friend
owned like the top 50 website
on the internet in video.
And he's like, these
guys are gonna crush me.
They're well-funded, I got nothing.
I won't be able to keep
up with the funding
and they're gonna win.
And fast forward two years,
YouTube sucks up all
the oxygen in the room.
Google buys them, Google puts
them into the search engine
and they end up being the
de facto video platform
on the internet post 2007, 2008,
and kind of monopolize the entire,
not kinda, they monopolize the
entire video sphere online.
So it puts all of us out of business
that own any video sites or small sites
where no longer existing.
And then it wasn't until about 2010,
where I started seeing a shift change,
a real change in the way
YouTube was doing things,
they introduced multi-channel networks,
they introduced a lot of preferencing
on big corporations and icons.
So it was about, it took me
till about 2013 where I said,
it's time to get back into this space.
It really seems to me that
the incumbent platform,
YouTube at the time is starting
to really deprioritize the small creator
and really prioritize those
multi-channel networks,
big influencers, large
brands, large corporations,
and our aunts and our uncles
and our friends and family
no longer really had any
kind of space or real estate
on these platforms anymore.
So we started Rumble in
2013 to really bring back
that fairness and really
help that small creator
get access to those tools, get
access to the monetization,
get access to everything that those MCNs
were giving creators access to.
And we built a pretty
good business in 2013,
and it was a good business
all the way up until 2020.
And then it became a really
good business in 2000,
I would say, starting in 2018 and forward
it became a really, really good business.
By 2020, everything hits the fan.
It was like 11 o'clock at night
in the middle of the summer.
And I remember a Congressman
signing up to our site.
And I was like, holy shit.
Like why is a Congressman
signing up to Rumble?
Like this being a Canadian,
a Canadian video platform.
That was a pretty big deal.
And I remember going to
my colleague and saying,
"Hey, is this real?
Is this a real signup?"
And we looked at it and
we think it was real.
It seemed like it was real.
And a week later,
I'm on the phone with this Congressman
and he asks me a simple, simple question.
If I put my content on Rumble,
will I be able to find it in
search if I search my name?
And when we're like, yeah,
that seems pretty standard.
It should come up in our search
if someone searches for you.
And he's like, "Well, that's
not happening anywhere
else on the internet.
It's not happening on YouTube.
So I am gonna bring it over to Rumble."
Within three months, less
than that, two months,
he accumulates over 300,000
subscribers on Rumble
and in the very same period,
over five, actually a longer period,
five years on being on YouTube,
he only had 10,000 subscribers.
So you can kind of see how that happened.
And when that did happen
and everybody noticed,
everything hit the fan.
Everyone started hearing about Rumble.
People were like growing faster on Rumble.
The message went out.
This Congressman was on TV,
telling everybody to go to Rumble.
- I know who the answer is
but we should tell people
who the Congressman was.
- It was Congressman Devin Nunes.
- Yeah.
- He was the very first person
and the political sphere
to come on onto Rumble
and realized this problem
that was happening.
And when it did happen, he was out on TV,
letting everybody know that,
hey, like I'm growing faster on Rumble
and I'm getting more views on Rumble
than I am getting on YouTube.
And it wasn't long after
that till started following
and jumping onto Rumble.
And it took us to we're in 2021 now.
And in August we saw the
largest month we've ever seen
on our platform, a
tremendous amount of growth
from where we were six months
ago, seven, eight months ago.
The largest single growth in
a single month was in August.
And we haven't looked back since,
and it's been super exciting,
we did the merger and I
wanna call it a merger,
well it's not really an acquisition.
And I think we should really
explore that a little bit more,
but the merger with you
and becoming partners with you and Assaf
is the next major moment in this business.
And I'm super excited to be here with you
and talk through this.
- So before we get into that stuff.
Can you just tell people a little bit
about what you actually have built?
Like when people think, oh,
you're trying to compete with YouTube
or you're trying to
compete with Amazon AWS,
like these sound like impossible feats
and you know as well as I, like,
I went into enough
boardrooms to tell people
what we were doing with
Locals and they're just like,
no, the big boys exist.
Like accept it and move on.
- Yeah and this is really like looking
under the hood and it's really important.
It's a great question.
So one of the things we did is
we did, when we built Rumble,
we built it the old
fashioned way, like I said,
I've been in this for two decades.
I've been working off bare
metal and my own servers
since the day I started in
2001 or two or whenever it was.
And I never really did it any other way.
All these fancy words,
cloud and AWS and Amazon,
I never subscribed to that.
And when we started Rumble,
we put in our own servers,
we put in, use our own
bare metal and we built out
our own infrastructure from the ground up.
And we didn't look back
in how we did that.
And it wasn't something that
I thought was necessarily,
it wasn't like, hey, we need to do this
because we need to compete against them.
It was like, hey, we need to do this
because it's gonna save us costs.
It's better.
It's just, we own everything.
It's, we don't wanna give
anybody access to that data.
We wanna make sure
that's all under our hood
and not under someone else's hood.
And that's kind of why we did it.
And you come to 2020 and
2019, 2020, and 2021.
It ends up being a real,
real good decision.
But that's not to say that we didn't look
into the future a little bit with it.
When we started Rumble, we
saw Rumble as like two things.
And one was to compete
aggressively against YouTube
and the video platform
as much as possible.
And, but if we successfully do that,
it means that we'll now have
the scale to go really compete
against all these
incumbent cloud services.
Remember when you look at
Google and Google cloud,
what do they have that makes
their infrastructure so large?
YouTube.
When you look at Amazon, AWS,
what do they have that makes
their infrastructure really large?
It's amazon.com and Twitch.
When you look at Microsoft
Azure, you look at X-Box,
you look at these things
that really allow them
to have real competitive advantage
on the infrastructure side.
When you look at Rumble
and now that Rumble
has become a formidable size, we now have
that advantage to really
offer a cloud services,
really offer a new rail.
And after what we've
seen in the last year,
that new rail is really,
really significantly needed.
As much as Rumble is
needed as a video platform.
I actually believe that
the actual rail, the cloud,
the infrastructure, the service
is really, really needed
for the entire internet.
The free and open
internet is under attack.
And we need to provide the
rail as a common carrier,
as close to a common carrier as possible
for everyone else out there,
all the other businesses,
all the other churches,
everything, universities,
it kind of spreads into
every sector out there.
And we really wanna provide
that infrastructure.
- So I'm sure many people
are watching this going.
So let me get this straight.
If Parlor let's say,
had been on Rumble infrastructure
using Rumble infrastructure
after January 6th,
would Parlor still be here right now?
- Absolutely, Rumble is still around.
- Right.
- I think that's a
testament to where we are
and what we're doing.
Rumble is around, and
Rumble will be around.
And we're gonna continue
to build that rail
and build that new economy for everyone,
not just for rumble.com and
Locals, but for everyone.
- And let me get this straight Chris,
our policy is that people can
basically say what they want,
and we're not gonna decide
who the winners or losers are.
And if maybe somebody broke
the laws of the United States,
they have a bigger problem
than Chris and Dave is that,
could we be doing something
so radical like that?
- Yeah, I think that the
best way to look at it
is that we've got to get to becoming,
it is close to a common
carrier as possible.
We're not a publisher.
We don't wanna get an editorial control.
We wanna tell people what
they can or can't say,
if you're having an argument
at the dinner table,
why can't you have that
argument when you're online?
If you're having a discussion
or having an opinion,
why can't that be online?
This is the free and open internet,
is as free as your dinner table.
There no difference in my
mind and there shouldn't be.
And what we've seen happen
in the last 10 years
on the internet is this huge tilting
to kind of shut everybody up regardless
of your political views.
They just, every, they wanna shut down
the conversation that we all
have at our dinner tables.
And that's just, it boggles my mind
because when you look
back 10, 15 years ago,
and you look at these incumbent platforms,
they were all preaching
the free and open internet.
I even think I saw Twitter,
Twitter verified or Twitter.
I'm not sure it's Twitter policy say
that they want a free and
open internet in Nigeria.
And like, where is that
in the rest of the world?
Like, there's still pretending
they want a free and open
internet, but it really is not.
And I think that, us
building the rails to that
and really providing an
open communication platform
like Rumble are small pieces,
but important pieces to making sure
the internet stays free and stays open.
- So I wanna flash back
to all the way in June
of this past year, June, 2021,
Assaf my partner in Locals,
and I, we met here in Miami.
We had a couple of plans,
we thought, all right,
we're gonna present this guy
with some partnership ideas.
We can work together in some ways.
And I've said this a
couple of times publicly,
but literally before the water
was even poured at the table,
we had sat down for about 20 seconds.
You said, guys, I wanna merge with you.
How do we make this thing happen?
So why were you interested in Locals,
created by this wacky YouTuber?
- Well, that's a pretty easy one.
You build something that
is really important.
And what you've built is
you've allowed creators
to basically build
subscriptions in their own way,
allowing creators to have
autonomy and independence
in a different stream of revenue.
Rumble has been primarily
since we started,
it's been based off of
advertising and advertising is
to be frank, it can be a
weakness in this environment,
and we don't wanna fall pressure
to that type of weakness.
So by having like having Locals
and having a revenue stream,
that's protected by subscriptions
and allowing creators
to have that independence is
something that I've admired.
And I've always wanted to get towards,
we've built Rumble Rants,
we've built in tipping.
But then I said to myself, like,
why would we compete against someone
that has the same philosophy as us
that thinks the same way as us?
And we're up against the largest thing,
the largest companies on the planet,
we're up against the monopoly.
It makes no sense to be doing it,
to be doing it with less
resources and being really small.
You can't fight like
trillion dollar entities
with a couple million dollars.
Like you're not gonna win.
It's just, it's impossible.
You need to really kind
of bring in all the minds,
bring in all the resources and really,
and really do it together.
And I felt like one of the
things that seems to happen a lot
is that everyone wants to
kind of build their own thing
and kind of go at it their own way
without really kind of doing
it together, collectively
in a unified way.
And I felt like, we've
been talking to Assaf
for quite some time.
I felt like there was a real
opportunity after meeting you
guys in person and then
doing it many other times,
following that meeting,
it just made more sense to unify
and to do this as a collective resource
and to put all our brains
together and to do it together.
And that's what this is,
this this isn't just me.
This isn't just you anymore.
It's not just, it's all of us.
And it's all of us gonna go up against
the monopoly and that's gonna take,
it's gonna take more than
just us at the end of the day,
we're gonna need more than
just a spotlight at this point.
I think this was the perfect merge.
It allows Rumble to be
a lot more defensible.
We now have a subscription revenue stream,
and it allows us to be a lot more bold
on the advertising front.
The things that we have planned.
And we've discussed on the
advertising stuff is really bold.
And I can't wait till
we go to market with those strategies,
but now that we have
Locals and we're together,
we can now do that and we can
do things and we can innovate
in the market the way we
couldn't innovate before.
So they, I think for me, it
was a no brainer to combine
and work with the two,
your yourself and Assaf,
I think, this is the perfect synergy.
- And for us,
it gave us not only the
infrastructure we needed,
but resources, but I
think you really hit it,
which is that we all vibe,
like we all know what the threat is.
We all want to fight it.
And you said collective a couple of times,
and it's like,
my audience freaks out
at the word collective,
but like sometimes you've
got to team with people
to beat these things.
So let's just get into some
of the specifics of the deal
and how we're gonna work together.
Because a lot of people
in my local's community
and on YouTube and on Rumble were asking
about some of the specifics.
So first off, Locals is gonna
continue to operate as is,
we just have better resources behind us,
Assaf will continue to run it.
You're not looking to take over Locals.
Anything else you want to say on that?
- Yeah, like the, our vision,
and it was from day one
is that we'll use Rumble
to funnel a massive audience
to Locals for your creators,
bring them more subscribers
integrate it into Rumble,
allow the Rumble audience
to really find Locals,
creators and subscribe to their pages.
A real true discovery for Locals
which drives the bottom
line for all the creators.
In addition to that,
the other thing that we
thought was really compelling
was in necessary and absolutely necessary
is to get Locals on the Rumble rail,
is to utilize that infrastructure
so that you're protected.
And that you can continue
to fulfill your promise
of allowing freedom of expression
and allowing people to
have their own opinions
and have their discussions
the way they want to have
without anybody impeding that.
And my philosophy is that the way Locals
is being run right now,
and it has been phenomenal.
There's no reason for anybody
to step in front of that.
And that's not what this is, what this is,
is that Locals is gonna
be running independently.
Rumble is gonna be running independently,
and we're gonna utilize those resources,
bring in that distribution from Rumble,
really help that Locals
community, and really
protect that Locals community
on an infrastructure
point of view, nothing else changes.
Why would anything else changes?
That's not gonna help anybody.
- Can you talk about the data
and content side of this also,
because when I started this thing,
it was purely because I needed a place
that I would own my content,
my video, my audio, et cetera.
And I needed a place
where if I got booted off everything else,
I could actually still
communicate with my audience.
That's exactly how we built Locals,
but I saw some people
there saying, oh, oh,
now Rumble is gonna have all of that data.
You won't have it as the creator,
but I don't wanna give you too much
of a leading question here.
That's actually not the case.
- It's funny, 'cause
I was actually talking
about this like a year
ago and I've been having
this conversation for
months since that first time
that I explored this.
I've always wanted every creator on Rumble
to own their data.
I think that's imperative.
I think I wrote an article
a long time ago about that.
And that was one of the key ways
to kind of really kind of
get back into this market
is really making sure that
the creators are independent
and own that data.
For us to like have that data on Rumble,
that's not the mission here.
The mission is to make sure
that creators stay independent.
Their mission is to
protect the creator economy
more than ever and protect their opinions
and protect what they wanna do.
It would be, it would make no sense
to be doing the complete
opposite of why these businesses
are succeeding today.
Like we are here to like
change the creator economy,
give them more autonomy,
give them more independence.
I really think this is the next wave
of web 3.0, call it whatever you want,
but it's surely the next wave.
And I think Locals is
on the forefront of that
and Rumble needs to catch
up and do more of that.
And that's what Locals allows us to do
is like now we can accelerate on that.
Imagine having all your
subscribers on Rumble,
being portable, that should be possible.
That's what we should stand for.
That's what the creator economy deserves.
Those are, that's their audience.
For us to be able to take that
away from them is not right.
And that's it and that's
what Locals is doing.
They've changed that if anything,
Locals is gonna get Rumble
to do the same thing
that Locals is doing, not the vice-versa.
- And to be clear, that's complete 180,
the reverse of what happens
on Twitter, YouTube elsewhere.
Like I have no way of contacting
my 1.7 or whatever it is,
million YouTube subscribers,
because they own the
access to those people.
I don't have direct
communication with them.
One of the things that I
saw pop up a couple of times
when we announced this
was people were concerned
that Rumble is a Canadian company.
You are a scary Canadian with
that draconian government
you have over there.
Do we have any plans on that front?
- So we did announce
that we were opening up
a US headquarters in Longboat
Key in Sarasota County
down in Florida.
So we'll be neighbors to Locals.
I know Locals is in Miami and
we'll be on the other side
of the coast, but yeah,
we're definitely having,
we're planting a large
presence in the United States
and we're super excited about that.
That's the business climate
in Florida is amazing.
The county has been amazing.
And one of the things I
like about it is that,
Rumble gets a lot of
support from small towns
in the United States and
big cities, but small towns,
a lot of it and going into a small town
is super exciting to me.
I think supporting a community like that
and really bringing Rumble
to a community like that
rather than picking a large
city is a super exciting,
I'm looking forward to it.
But yeah, I understand
everybody's concerns
about being in Canada, those are concerns.
I don't, we don't know
where that's gonna go
here in Canada yet, the
laws are still kind of,
they haven't been passed yet,
but it's definitely a concern.
I think a lot of companies
are expressing that concern.
And at this point right now,
like we'll have our US
headquarters in Sarasota,
and I don't think there's anything
for anybody to worry about at this point.
- Is there anything else on the tech side
that we should let people know
that maybe I haven't let them know
or Bongino hasn't let them know
or that you just want people to know about
what it is that we're building?
- So there's, the Rumble
cloud is something
that we're gonna put a lot of focus on.
Obviously, our first priority right now
is to make sure that we
get Locals onto this cloud.
We've brought on a lot of
customers on the cloud side
and it's funny
'cause we're not even really
proactively selling it.
We've made some statements that we have it
and we've had a lot of
incoming and we've onboarded
a lot of different clients,
some very large ones as well.
So there's gonna be a lot
of stuff on the cloud front.
We're gonna be launching that Rumble cloud
in the near future.
But in terms of Locals and Rumble,
there's gonna be a lot of tech
integration there as well,
not just on the cloud side,
but on the front side,
being able to access to
Locals content through Rumble,
being able to discover
it, having your accounts,
to be able to connect,
not on a data perspective.
So we're not taking the data,
but on a perspective of
like being able to say,
hey, you have a Locals account
and advertise that Locals
account on your Rumble page.
So you can go there and convert
and maybe even convert them
straight from the Rumble page
into the Locals community.
So there's a lot of work on that front.
We also have our new app coming out.
That'll be out in Q1 of
2022, hopefully sooner,
but let's say Q1 2022,
which is gonna have a
completely new interface.
I know that's been a huge complaint.
And I agree, when you're
a bootstrap company
and you never raised money
since like five, six months ago,
you kinda, you don't really
have the cash resources
to go out there and build
that fancy user interface.
You kind of focus on
the core infrastructure
which we have done.
But now that we were a
little more capitalized,
we can build that interface
that everyone's looking for.
And we have been, and
we're more working on that
every single day.
- So we do all that,
we fix the internet and then
we just hang out on a boat.
What do we do after that?
- Oh, I don't know about that.
But in terms of, we
got a lot of work to do
in terms of fixing the internet right now.
We have, we right now that
free and open internet
is under attack.
And I think it's gonna
take many years before
we fixed that, but definitely
that's the only thing that I
have on my agenda right now
is making sure that we fight back on that.
- Well, Chris, I just
want to say it is also,
I've mentioned it on the show.
We did an all stock deal here,
which we didn't have to do.
We had cash offers and to Assaf
I believed not only in the idea
that you've presented here,
but you and the team has
just been like this was,
this was all kind of a no-brainer,
even though it can get tricky with lawyers
and everything else, it all kind of fit.
And I think people are now seeing a hope
for that parallel internet
or social media 3.0
or whatever you wanna call it.
So I know you have work to do that perhaps
is more important than talking to me.
Any final thoughts?
- No, the work is to make
sure that the community
understands what this is and understands
that we're here for them and
we're gonna fight for them
and we're listening to them.
And I think that's really important
that they know that we're listening.
I go through every,
I try to go through as
much as I possibly can
in terms of comments and what they say.
One of the things I
noticed is that they say
that you sold, you sold,
but really it wasn't a sale.
It's really just combining
forces right now.
This is a merge.
This is a merger.
And I think, we're stronger because of it.
And we're listening to all
the feedback that's coming in.
And that's what I love about you guys.
And I think that's really
important is to always
really have our ear to the ground
and understanding what
our community is saying,
because we have to deliver
them what they want.
And if we don't, we don't
deserve to be in business.
- All right, here is what we're gonna do.
I'm gonna put you on the spot.
This was not preplanned.
But when we post this video,
I am going to ask you
to respond to questions
in my Locals community.
People can ask whatever they want,
and let's get you in there,
actually responding to people.
This is sort of the complete
reverse of what Zuckerberg
would do or Jack from Twitter
or the rest of these guys,
but let's get you in the community.
And if people have questions,
they can go to www.rubinreport.locals.com
and ask you questions directly,
right from the video itself.
How about that?
- Absolutely, I look forward to that.
I will do that.
And I will try to do that forever.
- All right, Chris,
I got nothing better to
do than save the world.
I look forward to continuing
the adventure with you.
- Sounds good, thanks a lot for having me.
- If you are looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about tech
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our tech playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, check
out our full episode playlist,
they're right over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.